et maintenant j'accueille andré gaillard
[Musique]
allô allô
allô nova
enfin passez moi l'inter et par urbain
épaules à la passe et moi l'inter paul
alaux joseph temmar mais qu'est ce que
tu veux ce soir je vais au ciné voir
quoi et vidéaste contrefont ce qu'il a
fait c'est un ave maria
allait aussi d'artagnan oui voulez vous
dire ami des digues se passera chercher
à dose c'est impossible pourquoi on ne
peut pas à chercher midi à 14h
alors la reine d'angleterre hier ici
catherine lalumière watts
alo'o fribourg a lui même c'est vrai que
j'allais faire des grosses dettes à rome
mais oui et pourquoi que je devenir le
boulevard des italiens
à l'eau bernard pons non ils ennuient
[Musique]
tout le monde en a parlé à retrouver
andré gaillard à paris dans le 15e
arrondissement
à 83 ans l'ex moitié des frères ennemis
vie dans une garçonnière perché au
cinquième étage d'un immeuble
en plein jour après je suis content de
vous voir
sur les murs de son studio sont
accrochés les souvenirs du duo qu'il
formait avec telly vrignaud dans les
années 60 et 70 le temps a passé mais la
dérision perd 6 non
crochet mais chemise mais je devrais en
faire d'après mon bon kiné la pièce
maîtresse de la caverne d'en dresser sa
bibliothèque de range tellement bien les
fruits que des reports
alors pour s'y retrouver andré a adopté
un système très élaboré
les représenter la bibliothèque
est pas numérotés mais il ya l'alphabet
alors si je cherchais un bouquin par
exemple valais la lettre était alors la
lettre t elle est là mais ça ne sais pas
ce que c'est
c'est dans cette bibliothèque pendrait
conserve quelques souvenirs vingt ans
d'une carrière dont il a passé le
flambeau à ses deux filles toujours très
proche de lui à leur manière elles
rajeunissent les frères ennemis en
formant leicester est menée à bien j'ai
regardé les ce que j'ai fait un ennemi
mais depuis tout petit mon atelier et
certains sortent interne certains mots
voilà voilà le ciel des fantômes
tellement fait mais on reprend la sq est
ouvert au phare à elle fait un rap à la
fin j'ai fait moi j'étais dans le fond
de la salle et les jambes je venais de
serrer la main en me disant qui est une
bonne continuité c'est quand même
important
bonne journée à toi aussi alors voir
sa soeur
est amer
loin des yeux mais pas si loin du coeur
les pouces d'andré gaillard vite à un
autre étage s'il a décidé de s'isoler
c'est notamment pour rédiger ses
mémoires en toute tranquillité ça fait
plus d'un an que fuient dessus
maintenant même temps j'étais un peu
inquiet mais comme j'ai appris qu'il y
en a eu il ya des gens qui ont mis trois
ans pour y créer un book un
jeu continue entre deux lignes andré
s'accordent un peu de bon temps dans son
quinzième arrondissement
l'humoriste qui a ses habitudes et ses
habitudes ça va le rugby
allez bonne journée au marché j'ai des
copains
le boulanger cse et c'est un bojan les
cas il y en a un autre là en face il ya
deux
semaines sera installé mais la bonne
femme est tellement imac je dirais plus
vendus afin d y aller sans plus et là il
va y avoir une petite boutique de alsace
hier le spécialiste des joutes verbales
fait toujours mouche et sa passion des
mots le conduit régulièrement chez deux
voisines libre elle revient très bien de
la mémoire andré gaillard on a à
revendre les libraires livre d'anecdotes
en ont d'ailleurs la tête qui tourne
oui qui veut protéger son trait fin a
par rapport à moi l'école communale et
on est rentré chez moi et qu'elle
pourrait faire un capital parce que
attendant l'ascenseur non la série sinon
oui quand ils rentrent il faut avoir du
temps voilà c'est pas mon prochain
passage au revoir
ben on va déjeuner dans un restaurant
que je connais qui est très bien voilà
une la france
andré nous emmène dans sa cantine en
face de la mairie de son quartier et la
maîtresse des lieux est sa première fan
bonjour
tout le monde enfants ça a été au tour
d'andré pour une raison c'est qu'avec
mes grands parents je regarde l émission
de maritie et gilbert carpentier et il
était il faisait partie de toute cette
époque là voilà et c'est vraiment mon
enfance et ont drainé pas insensible au
charme de la dame
[Musique]
est encore régalé c'est être délicieux
voilà
[Musique]
tout se termine bien je suis content
pour la vive la france venez travailler
menteur andré s'en retourne à ses
mémoires souhaitons qu'elle soit pleine
de ses bons mots et de l'esprit des
frères ennemis
[Musique]
dès maintenant la lumière se rallume sur
andré gaillard bonsoir bonsoir bienvenue
sur le plateau de tout le monde a parlé
alors andré vous êtes né le 19 décembre
1927 oui à paris oui vous avez 83 ans
alors votre père grand mutilé de la
guerre de 14 18 donc il était gardien de
square parce qu'à l'époque ont donné aux
grands blessés des décharges comme ça
vous vous êtes d'abord maquettiste
publicitaires en fait des affiches de
spectacles notamment celle du premier
spectacle de barbara à lécluse c'était
drôle parce que à la fin d'un spectacle
est le relais dans la salle alors je les
vallées de la loire que filiale audi ag
chez marconi m'emmerde il faut y vole
des photos sur les affiches que j'aime
par les photos je peux te faire une
maquette ben voilà fais-moi une maquette
apporte moi demain parce que je suis
comme ça le lendemain lui apporte de
maquettes c'est ça que je veux alors
demain on va tirer parti et puis je suis
passé à la fois la pochette du disque à
la fois la fiche du spectale exactement
alors ce genre d'expérience plus le fait
d'habiter rue devant pas loin de la rue
de la gaîté où il y avait trois
music-hall la gaieté bobino le casino
montparnasse tout ça vous donne envie de
monter sur les planches alors début
c'est le théâtre ensuite ça sera la
scène et ce qui est terrible c'est la
réaction de vos parents votre mère vous
dit tu es fou et votre père éclate de
rire quand même laborie mon père a dit
on va d'abord travail à l'école et puis
trouver un métier à prévoir et puis vous
allez faire une rencontre qui va changer
votre vie en 1949 vous faites votre
service militaire en allemagne lorsque
vous rencontrez un type que vous
qualifiez de merveilleux teddy vrignaud
vous souvenez de votre première
rencontre il était alité dans dans le
le 2ème escadron j'étais dans le
troisième et puis on était nommé
brigadier tous les deux et puis là on
avait on avait nos conversations étaient
sans être les mêmes il y avait des
exemples moi je l'adoré valfond salé et
renard lui c'était une bulle roi mais il
y avait toujours cette chose-là et et
puis bon ben la pensée des aides on n'a
pas fait je prends des vacances presque
alors voilà à l'armée avec teddy vous
monter un numéro ensuite il quitte
l'armée avant vous vous perdez de vue
miracles vous vous retrouver par hasard
sur les champs elysées teddy et déguisés
en indiens enfin il est torse nu à des
plumes partout et ils distribuent des
prospectus pour le film les tuniques
rouges voilà donc où ils raclent il y
avait une plume derrière la tête et
distribue torse nu majoritaire alors
tombés dans les bras l'un de l'autre
qu'est ce que tu fais moi je fais c'est
toi et lui il suivait des cours de
théâtre moi j'en avais suivi et on a dit
oui suivez libéral et là vous vous
apercevez très vite que vous aimez
effectivement les mêmes auteurs les
mêmes histoires vous n'avez pas
exactement le même humour mais la
dissemblance entre vous fonctionne très
bien en fait par exemple une chose toute
simple on est en voiture c'est lui qui
conduisait moi je conduisais pas et un
feu rouge il y a une voiture qui
s'arrête on regarde ni un bonhomme
et qu'elle compte on le regarde tous les
deux sens seule compte la ferté et on
éclate de rire avec ce type quelque
chose qui nous a fait rire en même temps
que des détails pour la même longueur
d'onde vous débutez ensemble sur scène
en janvier 54 à lécluse au début vous
parodier des chansons dramatique des
années 1900 mais on vous conseille
d'écrire des sketches et c'est là que
vous trouvé le secret de votre humour
qui est très particulier en fait parce
que tout est basé sur sur un rythme très
rapide sur des jeux de mots il ya un ami
qui m'a dit vous êtes marron qui parle
quatre langues oui c'est drôle vous vous
écrivez l'anglais en france fait oui
c'est vrai c'est très anglo-saxon tout
abri à chaque fois on était flatté parce
que quand on voyait les tyson un gros
show
alors tous les sketchs sont écrits à 2
vous êtes parfaitement complémentaires
et puis vous improvisez à partir d'un
objet d'un mot comme ça sans censure
vous laisser aller quoi je me souviens
d'un truc pendant deux heures on a
improvisé et on s'est marré mais
vraiment bas on s'est marré on a fermé
le truc qu'on écrive autre chose ouais
d'où ça vient d'où le nom frères ennemis
avant c'était et j'étais chez monsieur
était 10e place des ternes et puis on va
on se tait appelé au début justement j
ch.b je sais pas pourquoi de leur haie
et là on dira même biais il ya les
frères qui allait et puis bon et on
regarde dans la bibliothèque on voit un
fils des frères jean marc et les frères
tharaud la chronique des phrases et demi
les phrases et de faire opérer sur l'art
minable alors le succès arrive avec les
années 60 on vous demande même en 1964
de jouer votre propre rôle au cinéma
dans cherchez l'idole de bois rond avec
johnny hallyday enfin bon c'est vraiment
là la gloire avec gérard pirès vous
ferez elle court elle court la banlieue
de mes papilles avec jean yanne aussi
légère bonjour fait trois films et
gioria oui alors vous avez énormément de
succès à cette époque qu'est ce que
pensait que le succès est arrivé vite et
on a eu la chance de naître à saint
germain des primes c'était formidable
c'était fantastique
on avait des textes finement qui est on
des ont déformé d'été des textes pour ne
pas dire comme tout le monde et ça
fonctionne en manche est très très bien
alors vos parents ont réagi comme ans
parce que quand on l'a cette fois ils
étaient contournons il était heureux
comme tout ils sont venus nouveau à
bobino
la grande loi vos relations avec les
journaux ça se passe et comment à
l'époque ça se passait bien oh oui oui
oh oui oui de très très bien j'ai gagné
de l'argent à l'époque on a bien vécu on
a bien vécu
j'ai une maison que j'ai acheté une
maison à la campagne puis il avait il a
acheté aussi d'un truc super ou en
lorraine et mai salle est très bien ça
marchait bien ah bah oui absolument et
les filles ça se passe et comment les
filles vont bien mais teddy était un
type très très timide
les filles il attirait beaucoup les
filles et c'était à chaque fois je vais
remarqué parce que c'est pas sûr du tout
et vous mouah mouah mouah mouah de oui
c'était ça tombait sa tombe et où sa
tombe est probablement foot qui a
beaucoup compté mon métier maintenant
est important
quel a été le meilleur moment de toute
cette époque il ya des moments
formidables c'est à l'olympia
on avait un sketch qui terminait par la
tombola et puis un jour je sais pas le
méro le numéro 906 gagné un grand gars
ça fait marrer les gens et ça a duré une
minute et le siège au début vous êtes
donc trois minutes plus une minute des
cats à l'olympia le soir de la générale
ça fait 8 me
les templiers teddy on pouvait public
parce que je devais dire il est le type
qui comprenait pas et puis moi je
parlais en gros lot racontant une
histoire
tout entre le 13
et quel était le pire moment de cette
époque
moi j'ai une chose j'ai été engagé chez
march o weh est lui aussi les lui
j'étais pas très pour faire ça non il
n'était pas fait pour toi voilà et puis
un jour après 30 ans de carrière et 750
sketch le 1er novembre
1984 freddy vigneault disparaît sans
laisser la moindre trace un matin il
sort de chez lui au volant de sa 504
peugeot en n'emportant que des objets en
laissant son chéquier on l'a plus jamais
revu l'enquète n'a jamais été
officiellement close
en fait quelqu'un qui disparaît ouais il
c'est tout c'est la mort celle assassine
moi dans mon esprit et les d'ailleurs
dans le quizz qui paraissait à l'époque
il ya meilleur calendrier ya des phrases
une hyundai à teddy vrignaud disparu ils
ne mettaient pas mal est mort alors ça a
été
tout m'a dit des choses trop tard on m'a
dit des choses qui auraient pu me servir
on y parle envie que la police fait des
choses qui était que je ne connaissais
pas où ils allaient dormir chez la
grand-mère d'une
docteur jamais fait qu'ils dormaient à
vue a plutôt le il m'a jamais dit ça il
disparaît 7 et il y jouait de la guitare
il faut tel qu'on laissait sa femme et
tout ça c'était et un jour vous croyez
l'apercevoir dans la rue arrivé cet été
à rome ils fêtaient et l autre et devait
pas savoir les 2 1 ils sont devant une
vitrine dans la rue dupleix et moi je
suis à 100 m même pas 60 m $ je viens je
regarde mais figé et intact et vraiment
il se retourne
c'était ni là ni l'orage et je suis
rentré chez moi je me fais mes courses
vous dites j'ai longtemps cherché le
sommeil après ça sa disparition a oui on
va vous y voyez vous dites sa
disparition m'a mutilée oui et vous le
savez il ya une chose importante c'est
les collègues du vin du val colette
rivale la championne du monde de soi
parachute et qu'on avait presque me
comme régisseur et elle était
extraordinaire elles étaient en
coulisses et il y en un qui se trompait
elle envoyait machar peut-être mais
c'était drôle bonne ambiance quand il a
disparu tous les copains monde et il
faut que tu trouves un bertin
partenaires soit tu vas tomber ben oui
mais trouver un partenaire
on attendait 34 ans ensemble on retrouve
pas un partenaire tout de même s'il a du
talent on alors je cherchais et puis les
jeunes et les français si j'entrais
n'avait trouvé un auditorium des lycées
meilleur
est dans le coup je jeudi mais j'ai dit
à colette battue va le remplacer par du
chômage aurait fait c'est l'enfer est
elle à remplacer teddy d'une façon
extraordinaire
extraordinaire on a débuté au caveau de
la république devant 300 personnes et
j'ai eu la chance que le luron rencontre
une amie elle elle parle de demande
comment ça va dit dont ils ont monté un
numéro et ça marche a dit c'est dur
qu'est ce qu'on peut faire à dire le
luron et un mois après son producteur
m'appelait rendre évolué faire un gala
avec le luron oui monsieur il est arrivé
sous un chapiteau de 4000 personnes je
les veux rentrer j'ai vu rentrer coco
devant moi alors l'état bilan noir et
blanc eq talon aiguille j'ai regardé ma
recherche dit c'est pas possible elle
est déjà venue arrivé et on a fait les
mêmes rendements qu'avec teddy tout est
tombé au mais elle est là devant andré
pourquoi vous n'avez pas continuer avec
à l'heure elle est décédée crash est
décédé quatre ans après da quatrième
cancer un résident sûreté dit qu'elle
est l'hypothèse aujourd'hui qui vous
semble la plus vraisemblable en fait moi
il me racontait par sa vie avec sa femme
qui est les copains de maman marthe me
le racontait
sa magie fait pas tellement et quand
même et comme disait mais quand même tu
travailles avec lui et que c'est de lui
faire comprendre
et mais c'était que sordide tellement on
se connaissait vous allez voir on
répétait tous les jours de 10h du matin
à 3 heures il vient un jour et puis on
peut être petit déjeuner un machin qui
on parle de tout et de rien mvié pas
neuf bon je dis rien et puis d'un seul
coup du japon vise un truc aussi il ya
dix ans j'ai un copain des arts
appliqués qui m'a téléphoné il ya une
paye que j'avais pas entendu parler lui
d' iliad et ma vie et les problèmes avec
sa bonne forme d'essai et on est parti
sur la bonne femme non il m'a posé des
questions sur la bonne femme sachant qu
était lui nous voient ce qu'ils qu'il a
pu partir pour parce qu'ils osaient pas
divorcer par exemple il avait épousé
pour le pire et aimer les meilleurs donc
peut-être que plutôt que supporter cette
vie maritale qui lui convenait pas il
était parti refaire sa vie ailleurs
c'est possible penser qu'il s'est
suicidé non
je crois pas se propage
dans cette situation à laquelle je me
trouve on peut tout d'un coup tu
proviens survient surtout
il est peut-être toujours en vie parce
que finalement et xavier quoi un âge un
enfant différent souhaitable et c'est ce
que je me dis d'ailleurs un autre encore
est peut-être pas mais
cette histoire et s'ils revenaient là
vous lui diriez quoi d'abord bonjour
les politesses mais je crois qu'on
tomberait dans les bras l'un de l'autre
et c'était des choses qu'il est qu'ils
l'étaient pas
il n'était pas dans
mon père ma mère tout ça et je crois
qu'il avait pas cette attitude en
famille et l'avait pas dans le métier
vous savez comment c'est le métier on en
croise même à mes pneumatiques en détail
ce boum boum boum et mélèze lui l'un il
était et il était dur comme ça ils
chantaient des muscles mettant du temps
du tout le temps peut-être craquer oui
on voulait d'avoir détruit votre duo
surtout quant à colette à décéder et
j'avais un copain qui m'a dit lorsque
qu'elle était décédée
et que teddy avait disparu il m'a dit
c'est dur de travailler avec toi
c'est sûr alors vous poursuivez votre
carrière au théâtre cinéma les grosses
têtes un voyageur t elle et alors ce qui
est formidable dans votre histoire c'est
que votre grande consolation c'est quand
vos deux filles sylvia et valérie
gaillard reprennent les sketchs et des
frères ennemis sous le nom des soeurs
ennemies oui moi c'est formidable
elle fait même en épater quelle
satisfaction alors aujourd'hui vous êtes
nostalgique de cette époque là la grande
époque avec tes voeux aux bains fait
partie de ma vie ça a été ma vie alors
andré si c'était à refaire qu'est-ce que
vous ne referiez pas pareil dans cette
vie aia ya à faire vous reprendriez la
même vie avec teddy malgré ce qui s'est
passé oui certainement un s'il était
d'accord yapi avec lui remonté à
quelqu'un ce n'est pas possible de façon
on peut pas alors j'espère ce sera le
plus tard possible mais le jour vous
allez mourir qu'est ce que voulait qu'on
écrive sur votre tombe comme épitaphe et
si celle au-delà mais l'espérance un
assez bien merci on dresse est très
heureux de rallumer la lumière sur vous
merci merci merci et pour être sûr de ne
rien rater de il a l'habitude abonnez
vous il m'était impossible ou